I'm Dr Peterson.
Thank you.
First of all.
It's a great pleasure being here.
It's awesome to see you live.
I basically got into your work's just
earlier this year and I had an original
question,
but your talk today kind of made me
decide to change my mind.
I was going to ask,
um,
do you feel as though would you agree
with me in the sentiment that the left
has pushed so hard for total control of
our society over the last however many
years?
It's almost to a point where saying 2013
was a different time.
Um,
would you say that because they pushed
so hard,
they've created this backlash and the
backlash created caused them to backlash
back again.
So they doubled down with their ideology
and then they get,
they lose another argument,
they lose another ideological war.
They knew lose another me more and they
double down and they doubled down again
and again.
And they can't seem to mean.
They can't seem to argue.
They can't see,
they can't,
they don't want to have an intellectual
discussion.
And as an,
an interpretation of what you were
saying there is no,
there doesn't seem to be any,
any,
any care of what's right with them.
They just want power,
they just want,
they just want to win.
Um,
do you,
would you agree with the sentiment that
they're burning themselves out and
creating the mass red pilling of the,
uh,
conservative movement that we see going
on?
Would you possibly think that maybe
they've committed suicide and,
and talks like this,
people like yourself,
Ben Shapiro and others who talk to
people like the subjects that we do the
taboo of nowadays?
Um,
possibly that this,
this is the answer to defeat the leftist
stranglehold on our society.
I will untangle some of that.
Okay.
So first of all,
well,
first of all,
the first observation is a really
interesting one because you know that
things can go out of hand very,
very rapidly.
And the reason they do that is because
of positive feedback loops.
Now,
the thing that Kurzweil talks about is a
positive feedback that an intelligent
machine makes another intelligent
machine that makes another intelligent
machine.
And that's a positive feedback loop.
And that can spiral upwards out of
control very rapidly.
And that's when polarization is.
It's like,
I tap you,
you tap me,
I slapped you,
you punch me well up.
It goes.
Well,
I think that's partly why in the New
Testament,
for example,
there's an injunction that says turn the
other cheek,
resist not evil.
Why?
Because otherwise you get into a
positive feedback loop and then you
better look the hell out and things can
tilt very,
very rapidly.
I mean,
all you have to do,
look at what happened in World War One.
No one expected that.
It was like one,
one relatively minor member,
I think of the aristocracy,
if I remember correctly,
was assassinated in one minor little
country.
It's like bang,
everything fell apart.
And that's positive feedback loops.
Right?
And so that's what we're in right now
and we've got to be.
And that's a really chaotic time.
And so I would say maintain self control
and don't aim to win.
Amen.
Piece.
Because winning,
that's not peace.
It's better to aim for peace.
You know,
I've got this talk coming up in November
11th.
I'm quite worried about it because I
know there's going to be protesters
there and that they'd been emboldened by
the fact that they shut the torque down
before and I want to make a video.
I'll probably do it tomorrow,
telling everyone that comes to that
meeting to like watch their bloody step
and stay out of the gutter because you
just,
we're at,
we're at.
We're at a point now where under the
wrong circumstances,
if the wrong person does the wrong
thing,
that the consequences will be very
great.
Now we can't predict which action is
going to precipitate that and or even if
that will happen,
but it's chaotic enough so that it could
happen.
So you know,
also govern yourselves accordingly.
Now the problem is,
is that there are people who would be
happy if there was blood running in the
street.
They're the same sort of people that
shoot up high schools or kill innocent,
you know,
elementary school kids just to show what
they're made of and what they believe.
And that's a big problem.
But for the rest of us,
like hopefully calmer heads can prevail.
And so it really is important not to
win,
it's like fighting with your wife.
You don't when you can't,
because you have to live with her.
She can't win.
But maybe you can solve the problem and
bring about peace.
And so you've got to practice doing
that.
Practice restraint now.
And remember too that these people that
you're talking about who are radical
leftist is most of the time,
they're not like they're 95 percent like
you.
And if you pull them out of the mob,
they're just like your,
your neighbors.
Nineteen year old kid who's kind of
clueless and rebellious.
Right?
And who you might even like you put them
in the mob,
it's a whole different thing.
And so you gotta remember that too.
Oh,
the fear of social isolation kind of how
they're acting.
I saying no,
it's just that they're possessed by
these ideas,
but,
but only partially,
you know,
you hardly find it full blooded.
Absolutely committed radical leftist
activist,
you know,
like there are some,
but not very many.
Most of it is just fragmentary behavior.
And you have to remember that like when
the students come out to protest me was
a case,
particularly at mcmaster,
I have to remember these kids,
they're not much different than my kids.
They are when they're in a stupid mob
behind a hammer and sickle flag,
you know,
but,
but you don't want to make a low
resolution,
homogenous representation of them.
And so,
and so.
That's why again,
I think instead of winning,
you turn to your own development,
you do what you can to stop doing the
things that you're doing that aren't
good because you're not going to hurt
anybody if you do that,
all you're going to do is help.
And otherwise you'll participate in this
polarization.
And that's unless you want that,
you know,
there's a dark part of people that it's
part of the part that voted for trump
would like to burn things to the ground.
It's like the hell I know how people
felt when they went into the voting
booth.
It was like Hillary,
Hillary or trump,
you know?
And that's a,
that's a hell of a thing to say to hell
with it,
you know,
although I could,
I could certainly understand that
sentiment.
So we have to be careful and all of you
people who are here who are advocates of
free speech and who are theoretically
happy to come hear me speak,
it's like I really do believe in.
I truly believe this and this is
something I learned in part from social
knits and then part from y'all missed
that the way that you set the world
straight is by constraining the
malevolence in your own heart.
And that's no joke,
man.
That's no easy thing and that's a good
voyage for people to go on if they want
something difficult and worthwhile to
do.
So.
Thank you very much.
Okay,
just a quick thing.
We're not gonna have time for pictures,
so you're.
Unless you're yours is the last
question.
Okay.
So sorry to everybody else,
but you're the last one.
Okay.
Hi Dr Peterson.
Thanks for coming.
Uh,
my question is a little bit off topic
from everything else tonight,
but I really wanted to hear what you had
to say about it.
I work in residence life here at UBC and
in the community where I am.
We were recently affected by a suicide
of someone who lived in our community
and that I was upset about it,
not just because obviously it's a
horrible thing to have happen,
but also because Rez life in the
university,
like they talk all this talk about self
care and your mental health is so
important to us.
But then things like this still happen.
So I wanted to know,
like if you think like,
what do you think the university should
be doing to keep stuff like this from
happening in the future?
Well,
it's not self evident that it's the
university's responsibility and the
reason for that.
I'm not saying it isn't.
Okay,
I'm,
I'm saying it's not self evident that it
is because different institutions can
only do so many things and we are
already recording the universities to
educate and to act as substitute parents
increasingly.
And to take on the role of judge,
jury and executioner as
there are more,
what should be criminal cases being
handled within the university?
Say,
um,
having said that,
you could ask the broader question is,
well,
what do you do to help people be
sufficiently in love with life so that
they don't wish to end it now?
And I've tried to puzzle through that
for a long time and that's partly why
I've written the things that I've
written.
It's partly why I've produced the online
programs that I've produced,
you know,
and so we know that if you do,
if you have students do the future
authoring program,
for example,
they're much less likely to drop out of
university about 30 percent less likely
and their grades go up.
And that's especially true if they're
male and marginalized.
It has a bigger impact on those
communities.
And so,
you know,
I've tried to get university's interests
now the data's there,
but they're not.
And it's very difficult to get a big
bureaucracy to move.
A big,
big is a mobile.
So I'm not sure if there's anything they
can really do about it that it's
certainly possible that the things that
they're trying to do about it or making
it worse,
you know,
that's another thing that you learn if
you're a good social scientists,
just like there was evidence,
and I don't know if this is still the
case,
but.
But there was good evidence.
I looked into this about 15 years ago.
Say you want to prevent suicides,
suicide hotline in your town and you
advertise it.
What happens?
Suicide rate goes up because you're
advertising suicide,
right?
And lots of lots of interventions are
like that.
It's really,
really hard to make things better and
it's really,
really easy to make them worse.
And so that's another problem.
You get these big bureaucracies,
let's say,
and there hypothetically motivated by
positive intentions and I would say
hypothetically again,
because it takes an awful lot of work to
help someone straightened out.
It's no joke,
especially if they're in real trouble
and they put in place these structures
that are designed to help but they don't
ever evaluate them and they could easily
be making it worse.
So,
so I don't have a straightforward answer
to that question.
Um,
I think that.
Well that's,
that's the only answer I have.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Okay.
Yep.
So that's the end of the show.
If you're in the first two rows,
you can stick around and get some
pictures.
Otherwise,
a drive safe and yeah.
Thank you.